quoique
des cris de douleur et de colère à
l'annoncé du verdict des femmes
s'effondre des points se lève la police
s'interpose en pleine cour d'assises les
familles des six coaccusés viennent de
comprendre qu'aucun d'entre eux ne
rentrera chez lui ce soir les jurés ont
retenu les qualifications requises par
l'avocate générale meurtre et complicité
de meurtre
le fait qu'ils aient retenu complicité
pour pour tout le monde ça m'apparaît
assez cohérent parce que comme je les
dis comme je lé martelé pendant ma
plaidoirie
sans cette action commune sans cet élan
commun on ne serait jamais arrivé à ce
résultat la plus tôt dans la journée
l'avocate générale qui s'était dite
sensible remords et regrets formulés par
l'auteur des coups de couteau mortels
mais maintenait l'intention d'homicide
avait requis 20 ans à son encontre
les jurés se sont montrés plus cléments
l'homme de 27 ans est condamné à 15 ans
de réclusion criminelle pense que le
moment qu'il attendait le plus mais qu
ils appréhendent help us aussi c'était
effectivement le ce qu'il pourrait dire
à la famille mais la façon qui pourrait
avoir de s'adresser à eux de dire la
vérité de s'exprimer librement sur ce
qu'il a pu faire
et d'espérer même si c'est compliqué une
forme de pardon le verdict je crois
qu'il attendait moins qu'il s'était
résolu à l'accepter quel qu'il soit pour
les autres c'est correct mais pour
l'auteur celui qui a frappé à mort frère
notre ami notre cause hein je pense que
15 ans moi j'ai dit que là la justice
n'a pas été juste pour le reste des
coaccusés le choc est rude des familles
déchirées se renvoient la responsabilité
du drame
certaines implore le pardon des victimes
qu'il accorde dignement la défense qui
réfute la thèse de l'agression délibéré
était convaincu d'obtenir la
requalification et de ramener toute
l'histoire à une simple bagarre qui
aurait mal tourné
si c'est vrai que la bagarre commence
avec lui jamais il n'a demandé avec qui
que ce soit de porter des coups de
couteau à monsieur diedhou et c'est ça
la question fondamentale en répondant
oui pour lui pour nous la cour d'assises
a commis une injustice et c'est pour ça
que d'ailleurs que nous avons décidé
d'interjeter appel après plusieurs
minutes de confusion d'invectivés de
tension le calme est revenu dans la
salle d'audience
les différentes parties civiles ont dix
jours pour faire appel de cette décision